so Sara just said my name is Adam
carpenter and I had the developer
business growth team in Google Play as
mobile developers one of the most
powerful resources we have available to
us is our data with data we can
understand what's happening right now
and we can also look back and try to
identify why that's occurred our data
lets us identify problems in the game
find solutions and ultimately grow our
businesses now in terms of this
presentation I'm going to talk through
some patterns some trends and some
insights that we've been able to
identify with the data at Google Play in
each of these three areas additionally
I'm going to share a number of key
benchmarks across them that you can take
back to your team's compared to the
native from your own data warehouse and
identify whether there are problems in
your games that you can maybe try and
solve now to start off first thing I'm
focused on retention and for me like
when you think about installs retention
three of those key KPIs for installs
performance is like the retention number
itself that date the buyer conversion
from your installed cohorts and the
average revenue per install but in my
mind retention is kind of the most
fundamental metric for us because if you
can't retain your players you can't make
any money if you can retain them you can
always figure out how to make money off
of them and one other note I want to
make for this presentation for the
purposes of the numbers in this section
I'm gonna call day 1 retention as the
day of the users first session start and
day 2 is the next day I know great many
of you tend to use retention is kind of
base zero so if you're kind of used to
thinking that nomenclature just subtract
one from each date to give you some
benchmarks and an understanding of kind
of what retention looks like day to
retention looks like across the top
couple hundred apps on Play 38% that's
the median value and that's kind of a
good target to shoot for it and think
about it but if you really want to
strive for excellence if you really want
to be in the top decile shoot for a day
- retention of about 52% another way to
think of this though is that our day -
retention tends to range between 22% and
52% but if we flip it around it actually
means that 48% to 78% of the users who
install and play our games for the
first time today won't be back tomorrow
they just won't come back it's really
kind of a staggering number when you
think about how much time and effort we
devote to creating our games how much
money we spend on acquisition and one of
those questions that I had when I was
working on the developer side is how can
I improve my retention is it good enough
what I'm hoping to do here is kind of
show you some signals that occur in the
very first day that can help you
understand whether your retention is
good and if it's not maybe some things
to check for to potentially improve it
so when I was on the developer side and
we were looking at installs performance
and their retention on the first day
generally speaking what we would look at
is the level that users got to or the
tutorial checkpoint that they reached
however those tend to be game specific
metrics and they're not really useful
core comparing across games because
people level wildly wildly different
rates depending on what the game is
tutorial checkpoints all vary but a
metric that we've been able to develop
at Google Play which is much more of an
apples to apples comparison looks at the
amount of time that users spend on their
first day and compares it to the day two
retention rates so to give you an idea
what this kind of looks like broadly
across the ecosystem and this is for
kind of the top 200 iat games you end up
with the curve that looks like this
starts off with let's say maybe 18-inch
percent and steadily trends upwards with
these successive minute played and of
course this kind of makes sense there's
a reasonable assumption that the more
people play on the first day the more
likely they are to return since the more
they play the more likely they are
they'd be having fun where this data
gets a bit interesting is when we
actually take those top couple hundred
games and break them out into quartiles
and so what we're looking at here is the
top couple hundred games broken out
based on their day two retention what we
can actually see is that by and large
each of these quartiles exhibits largely
the same pattern after the first ten
minutes they all curve upwards into the
right with the steadily decreasing slope
but it's in the first ten minutes where
the most interesting stuff starts to
emerge zooming into that we can kind of
see here that there's kind of very
different shapes and experiences in
patterns that emerge just within that
first ten minute window the top quartile
the the green the Green Line here
they start out strong and just steadily
increase but the blue line the second
quartile down you actually see this
short 90 second window where retentions
largely flat and only then does it begin
to pick up and that pattern actually
increases once you get down to the third
quartile this particular line here
looking at the 1/4 of those top games
that shows retention largely flat for
the 4th minute but in a number of games
that we looked at you can actually see
that flat period extend out all the way
to ten minutes and then once we get into
the bottom quartile the worst performers
you'll actually you can actually see a
retention decline across the first few
minutes and only then begin to rise so
to kind of give you some context and
understand just how impactful this first
5 or 10 minutes is what I want to look
at is the performance of the top
quartile the green line the best
performers versus the fourth quartile
the red line here and what this graph
shows is the amount of time played on
the first day on the x-axis and the
cumulative percent of lost players on
the y-axis so looking at that fourth
quartile they actually lose 46% of their
new installs by the fifth minute and
they lose 58 percent of their installs
by minute 10 basically that fourth
quartile and these are all like really
strongly performing games half of their
players don't even last 10 minutes in
the game in contrast the top quartile
the best performers they see only 17% of
their users lost at minute five and only
24 percent of their users lost at minute
10 now think of this from your own game
and your own perspective what could you
do if you were in the bottom quartile to
move your retention up and effectively
be able to retain over twice as many
users on day two and all the following
retention days how much would that help
you're down and how much would that
improve your revenue two of the
anti-patterns that we've been able to
identify in Google play's data or what
I've kind of started dubbing the flats
what we see here is largely flat
retention that persists for the first
five to ten minutes and only then does
it begin to rise and the other one that
we've identified kind of calling it the
gorge here is where we actually see
retention falling for the first couple
minutes and only then beginning to rise
so these are two kind of patterns that
are worth checking for in your own game
data get your data teams get your data
scientist feature
be business analyst actually pull this
and see what your games looking like and
if you do find that this is occurring in
your game here's some things to think
about because all of these have adverse
impact on that first five to ten minute
experience large secondary downloads
especially of users on our strong Wi-Fi
connection are gonna cause them to
bounce out of your game likewise if your
tutorials aren't fun if they aren't
representative of what the game really
is that can alienate players in
additionally slung slow loading times
are important to consider because your
new users are not yet invested in their
games so if you experience a lot of slow
loading screens they're more likely to
quick at quit out and go to a game
that's loads a near-real-time and
finally I would say think about your
lobby experience if a user coming out of
the tutorial doesn't know how to get
back into the action how to start
building their base or how to have fun
they're probably gonna get confused and
they're probably gonna leave
moving on to engagement you think about
kind of what most of us want and
certainly wanted this one it's work on
the developer side is we always want
more users since the more uses we have
gives us greater ability to monetize
during our supply-side sales and our
demand side events it also allows us if
we're showing ads in the game to show
ads to a significant great number of
users in addition to increasing our Dow
we also want to maximize our downnow
ratio since the higher that is it means
that fewer users are turning out of the
game and that they're coming back every
single day in an ideal world our down
would be equal to our Mau
meaning that nobody would ever turn out
of the game they'd come back every
single day but we know that this isn't
the case players veteran players turn
out of the game new installs turn out
because of poor retention even our kind
of frequent users don't come back each
and every day due to a lack of strong
return mechanics and so there's two kind
of Stu Commons stickiness metrics that a
lot of developers look at these would
like the down wow ratio and the down mal
ratio and kind of to give you some ideas
about what you should shoot for 55% for
a Dow Wow ratio puts you right at the
median so that's kind of a good starting
place and 31% for that down now ratio is
kind of again a good starting place to
shoot for but ideally you want to be
much better than that and something to
consider when you're looking at it and
trying to improve these relationships or
these ratios
is actually the relationship between the
two of them this is the plot that I had
never done on the developer side they
didn't really have enough data points
but in leveraging the Google Play data I
was able to create this and what it had
does is it has the dow l ratio on the x
axis and the down mound ratio on the y
axis and what we can actually see is
this very strong linear relationship
between the two and what this helps us
to understand is that we want to
increase our monthly active users and
our monthly uniques we can actually
start not by testing changes that
function over an entire month but test
changes that work in seven-day intervals
and one of the big advantages is so you
won't have to wait 28 to 30 days before
we start getting results back we can
actually see results coming back in
seven days and effectively within any
given window of time we can run four
times as many tests if we're focusing on
weekly versus focusing on monthly but
one of the other interesting things that
we can do is we can actually pull it all
the way in this is a metric I started to
work with the Google Play it's not
something I'd ever use on the developer
side and what it does is it looks at the
percent of today's da you who come back
tomorrow and it's just trying to
understand is a loose proxy for churn
how engaged are our users now if we take
that plot from before and instead put
this down return percent on the x-axis
and the dowel ratio on the y-axis what
we actually see is that again it's
positive and linear and what this kind
of tells us is that if we want to
increase our stickiness factors the most
important thing for us to do is start
focusing at the daily rate it's hugely
important and it's advantageous because
if you think about it
weekly versus monthly you can run four
times as many tests daily versus monthly
you can run depending on how you do your
month 28 or 30 times as many tests and
so fundamentally the most important
thing you can do to boost your active
users and your engagement is focus on
tomorrow focus on what is actually going
to bring your users back and keep them
engaged now it's kind of important to
understand to think about how do you
know if you're doing well enough
especially kind of this new metric that
most of you probably haven't experienced
and so here's kind of some target ratios
looking across the entire top couple
hundred apps couple hundred I a P apps
that you can take back and compare
and you know that 77% number that's kind
of important when you shoot for but
really shoot for that high side 84% try
to figure out how do you get your users
to come back each and every day and a
few ideas a few things that are worth
considering are your return mechanics
your social systems and your push
notifications because all of these have
a huge impact in case of return
mechanics let's really celebrate them
let's make sure our users are totally
aware of them that the return mechanics
are aspirational that they're rewarding
that users are really strongly
incentivized to come back each and every
day to receive them in the case of the
social systems let's really really
leverage them because if you think about
it the games that have very strong clan
systems alliances good chat groups
substantial friends benefits in those
games effectively your players do the
work for you if I'm a player and I have
friends in the game who are relying on
me it's in my best interest to be there
and likewise if they're relying on me I
want to be there for them so think about
your social systems and whether you can
strengthen the existing ones or add new
ones and let your players do the work
for you
and finally on the push notifications
side think about how you can personalize
them how can you create personalized
push notifications targeted just towards
an individual user or a segment of users
as opposed to effectively spamming all
users at all hours of the day think
about trying to target push
notifications around the normal time of
day that a user plays is that's going to
be much more compelling and much more
impactful now the last thing I want to
kind of focus on monetization and this
is what I'm going to be talking about
it's a metric that I use really
successfully and really effectively when
it's working on the developer side and
what it does what it will do is it's
gonna help us understand and answer the
question of our payers healthy
generically speaking the industry has
kind of reference singular data points
made claims to the effect of only 2% of
payers actually pay however that's kind
of horribly misleading as a statement
because that's generally speaking that's
gonna be focused more on that daily by
our conversion number it takes know it
takes into account or doesn't take into
account the percentage of users who are
willing to only open their wallets on a
weekly monthly or even quarterly basis
and so what you can kind of do to take a
look at to understand your payers health
is a ratio that we call POW Dow
and what it is is the percent of your
daily active users the users are active
today that it paid within the preceding
x-day period in terms of the time frame
that I used to like to look at the ones
I found that we're most impactful were
the seven thirty ninety and one-year
time frames and these are extremely
valuable because they allow me to do
things like compare the users who
purchase within a week versus a month or
the quarter versus a year and the other
thing that's really important and really
impactful with how down since it's a
measurement of the users who have
already paid in your game it kind of
helps to you to understand the audience
in your game that's willing to pay
because we're always trying to convert
first-time users but then once they've
converted we need to create incentives
to actually get them to continue to open
their wallet again on a regular basis so
what I'm going to talk through here is
an example game and kind of show you
some trends and some patterns in the
daily buyer conversion and how they've
impacted various Powder ratios there's
three events that I want to call it on
this chart and the first is this medium
duration event that occurred basically
at the end of January to the beginning
of February maybe two two and a half
three week period and what we saw here
is that this event provided a
substantial increase to the daily buyer
conversion the other two events are
event B and C each of these occurred for
about a day
they were sales and they created a
substantial 130 percent increase in that
daily buyer conversion
both all three of these are really
really effective but it's interesting to
see what they did with the Powder ratios
so looking at the seven-day ratio where
we can actually see is that event a was
extremely effective at monetizing a very
wide number of users and effectively
this event it actually caused a lot of
non buyers or occasional buyers to pay
and open their wallets during that time
versus events B and C which got
significant increases to buyer
conversion on that date but it didn't do
much to incentivize the occasional
buyers to open their wallets in pay so
something that you can think about as
you monitor the performance of the game
of the supply-side sales and the demand
side events in your game try to
understand who is actually paying during
their periods those periods
what is what are the motivating factors
what are the incentives what is kind of
driving those players to open their
wallets and you can also not just the
seven-day but I was mentioning you have
the 30 day that you can look at you have
the 90 days you can look at you have the
one year or even the lifetime but just
always try to understand when you're
running sales and you're running events
what incentives are they creating for
players how are they are they
aspirational are they desirable are the
excellent value for money but what's
kind of that motivation so in terms of
the Powder ratios I can't give you
explicit values that you could take back
but what I can give you a standardized
ratios the reason is that Kaunda is
intimately tied to your daily buyer
conversion and some games will have a
daily buyer conversion a half a percent
some games with sophisticated
monetization models it might be as much
as 3% but what you can do is take your
daily buyer conversion and if you look
at your seven-day pound out value it
should be four times higher the 30-day
value should be eight times higher the
twelve a ninety days should be twelve
times and if you look at that rolling
365 day window it should be about 15
times higher than your daily buyer
conversion another advantage of kind of
powder is the inter period comparisons
within your game take a look at what
this is is looking at the daily buyer
conversion in this case the hypothetical
1/2 percent and the scaling factors from
the previous slide what we would see
here is there's a reason Beck's vacation
that six percent of this games Dow would
have paid somewhere between 31 and 90
days ago in an incremental 5% of the DEA
you would have paid somewhere between 91
and 365 days ago if this was your game
that would be 11 percent of your DEA you
so think about how can you actually
incentivize these players
how can you shift those effectively
quarterly buyers to being monthly or how
can you reactivate those lapsed buyers
now let's say you do kind of start
monitoring of condo type metric and you
are trying to understand if there's
opportunities if there's room for growth
here's a few things to consider let's
say your game that does run supply set
offers figure out whether you can better
segment them can you put constraints on
the amount that people can purchase can
you segment by average transaction value
and in doing so limit the amount of
assets that users can get so they can't
stockpile
horde and therefore have to purchase
more frequently also think about it if
you see a large percentage of your users
haven't paid an extended amount of time
create last buyer offers for them and
almost like treat them like starter
packs because the primary goal if
somebody hasn't paid between ninety one
and three and sixty five days ago is to
provide them with a compelling value
proposition to get them to open their
wallet perceive good value and be
willing to pay again and then for a lot
of the users who are active think about
whether you can personalize the events
that you're providing to them in the
game and do so in a way that causes them
to drain assets quicker and therefore
it's strongly incentivized to open their
wallets in pay now just kind of wrap up
real quick and revisit each of these
sections we were looking at retention
that first five to ten minute period is
absolutely essential and it has such a
critical effect on your day two
retention in all the following days so
it strongly suggests going back in
generating metrics like that day one
minutes played versus day two retention
and see what it looks like in your game
and on the engagement side think about
how you can focus on tomorrow how can
you create really compelling engagement
mechanics return mechanics of social
systems that will bring players back
into the game make them want to return
each and every day and finally on the
monetization front think about your
power ratios and how they compare to the
daily buyer conversion and use that to
generate insights as to where users are
spending how frequently they're opening
their wallet and the size of your player
base who's only paid once and a quarter
or haven't paid and up to a year thank
you very much
you